I'm very close with my brother and my  brother has proven to me on so many  occasions that he is correct when we  debate something so my brother has  proven himself to be the man in my  opinion and so when my brother Gideon  says Leia we're doing this I'm like okay  because I've seen like I've [ __ ] tested  him I know that he's right honestly if  my brother says Leia change your shoes  I'll change them I did the other day I  went to do a podcast with Iman gaji and  Gideon was like Leia don't wear those  shoes wear those I was like okay my  brother told me to stop doing Wings on  my eyes like the the makeup I go okay  because I trust his opinion I comply  with everything my brother says what  you're saying is everyone needs a Gideon  in their life